this is a production of cornell
university
thanks larry as larry mentioned we're
running a little late already so i'm
going to go through these slides fairly
quickly because i think it's probably
a bit of review for most of you
and that will leave more time for
questions and answers afterward
so in 2018 the federal farm bill
required
that
all the industrial hemp research pilot
programs that we had operated from 2017
up until 2021 they all had to expire
at the end of 2021.
it also said that in order to continue
to administer a hemp program in the
future states either had to have a usda
approved hemp
program plan
or the usda was going to take over
administration of the programs in the
states so we opted to submit a plan our
plan was approved in october
of 2021 and we have been been running
that program
ever since
our program plan can be found on the
usda hemp website if you're looking to
if you really want to get into the
details you can just google usda hemp
program and you'll see all the state
programs
so this is important and i think
there
you all should know if you are a
registered grower if you have been i
mean in the past in the pilot program
you should have received probably a
dozen emails about this
but anyone who had the the license in
the pilot program that license has
expired regardless of the date on the
authorization that expired by active
federal law at the end of 2021
so if you if you want to grow this year
or god forbid you are growing this year
under the old license you need to get in
touch with me quickly
also new this year
we are
requiring a license to sell hemp seed in
new york state
that license is good for three years
there's a hundred dollar application fee
the hemp seed can only be sold to
registered hemp growers
we have a fairly detailed hemp program
guidance document on our website
the website address is there at the
bottom of the page we also have adopted
regulations
to administer this program and our
regulations follow
pretty much to the letter the
requirements that the usda has put in
place and that the farm bill put in
place so we don't have a whole lot of
uh superfluous regulations uh in there
we didn't regulate for fun we regulated
exactly what we needed to do
those regulations are also found on our
website
we're we're really happy to have the
regulations in place because as many of
you know in the past you had to do the
research partner agreement which was
more or less a contract between you and
the state and it outlined what you were
responsible for and what we were
responsible for but there was still some
room for ambiguity in there the rags
really have done away with that
ambiguity so we're pretty happy about
that and it hopefully should add clarity
and certainty for all of our growers
so new for the new
in 2022 under the usda approved program
in addition to submitting the
application to us and the 500
application fee you also have to submit
an fbi background check this is a
federal requirement
the background check can't be any more
than 60 days old at the time when you're
submitting it
and the only thing that really will
disqualify you on that background check
from getting a license is a drug related
felony conviction within the last 10
years
i've seen a lot of rap sheets it's
unbelievable
but as long as you don't have a drug
conviction you're all set
got lots of convictions but
no no felony drug convictions in the
program
also new this year total thc is the
standard that's also a federal
requirement
so we're testing for total thc and the
standard is still 0.3 percent
we will not be the primary sampler or
tester as we have been in the past
so growers that are licensed in the
program now will have to contract with a
certified sampling agent we have a list
of those folks on our website
with chuck schmidt is with me here today
he coordinates how many
is it on here
we have probably
60 i believe uh certified sampling
agents and we have 22 labs identified
they're listed on our website too but
that is a
model that we had to to enter into
because the usda requires now that every
lot of hemp is sampled
and that was just more than than we
could do with the staff that we had so
we had to go to this privatized model
which is what the usda does in states
where they administer the program
you cannot sample your own crop so you
can't be a sampling agent
and a grower
and growers can't
can't sample their friends crops so
nobody who's got a license can be a
grower and no employee
of a licensed grower can be a sampler
also new this year and this is fairly
standard practice with most farm
operations but
a lot of folks that are growing hemp
have not done other farming you need to
register your fields with the fsa the
farm service agency in the county
that you are growing in or the county
close by not every county has an fsa
office anymore but the fields need to be
registered with the fsa and then they
report those locations to the usda who
in turn reports them to the dea the drug
enforcement agency so
this is still
a highly regulated plant and
[Music]
hopefully
that may change in the in the future
so here's some reasons that
an application may be denied if it's in
incorrect or incomplete
the drug-related felony that i mentioned
before
if you don't submit the background check
that's a problem
if you're growing on a field that's
registered to someone else we can't we
can't have that because if
if if that field goes hot and you've got
two people registered there they're
gonna do like this who's responsible for
the hot stuff so
you cannot have co-located
registered field
you cannot grow in an area that's zoned
residential and you cannot grow in a
residence or in an attached garage i
have a
you wouldn't believe how many people
want to grow in their bedrooms it's
very
surprising to me but it does come up
failure to sign the application and
failure to submit the application fee
would also be reasons that we would have
to deny it
i try to work with people if they have
other than the drug problem
i give people a chance to cure their
applications and don't charge them an
additional fee but
it just
slows the process
all right as i've mentioned every time
i've ever given a presentation
it's really advisable to know where
you're going to sell the stuff before
you plant it
you don't want to be in a situation at
harvest time and have a barn full of
hemp and then call me and say what am i
supposed to do with this
i i don't know i'm not a broker i'm just
a regulator so you really should know
where you're going to sell it before you
plant it
also zoning is a local issue in new york
state so you need to check with your
town as to what the zoning is the state
does not
not administer zoning new york is a home
rule state so the zoning is left to the
localities
we
have to inspect hemp growers at least
once in the three-year license cycle you
won't be getting inspected every year
although we do reserve the right to
inspect you more than once in the three
year cycle
know the varieties know the
characteristics of the varieties that
you're going to grow do they have a
tendency to go hot
with this you know this is a much more
things are much more strict than they
used to be we don't have any wiggle room
really so if you come back with a
um
a sample that's above point
above one percent
you have to enter into a corrective
action plan with us and it's a two-year
process
and it's just a lot of headaches and if
it's if the stuff comes back really hot
i'm compelled to notify the u.s attorney
general the new york state attorney
general in law enforcement so know what
you're growing and and keep an eye on it
and make sure you're not going to get
into trouble
okay
having said all that
we're hoping in the
coming years to be able to reduce the
burden of sampling and testing by doing
performance base sampling and that would
exempt some people from sampling if
they're growing varieties that are known
to to be
compliant don't have a tendency to go
hot it's also going to um you know fiber
and grain varieties typically are not
going to
be as likely to go hot as cbd so that
would be a factor that would enter into
it
if you're using certified seed that
would certainly help and the history of
the grower would help us make that
determination as to whether or not you
could be exempted if you've been a
compliant grower you've got all your
paperwork filed that that would
really work in your favor
okay so far this year because the
program expired at the end of last year
uh we at that time we were up to 70 uh
yeah 745 growers that represented about
30 000 acres of registered land but
everyone's license expired so we started
from scratch
we now have 229 licensed growers with a
little over 4 500 acres
outdoors and 2.5 million square feet
indoors registered
and as i mentioned before we have the 60
certified sampling agents and 22
identified labs
so
questions regarding marijuana and cbd
processing or sales
are not
me we do not do that at ag and markets
so that's those should be addressed to
the office of cannabis management and
pat will be following me here shortly so
he can uh
help you out a little bit if you have
questions but there's their information
if you have marijuana related
questions i can leave that up for a
minute
and here's
if you do have questions about hemp
there's our website our industrial hemp
email address and the hemp hotline
so feel free
it's a red phone
no no right exactly
so if you do have questions please you
know feel free to uh
to call anytime and we'll see if we can
help you out
and that's the end of that so i can take
questions now if i don't get to your
question or if you'd rather not ask it
in public i'm going to be around most of
the day so you can hunt me down and i'll
be more than happy to talk to you
the question is if the zoning in your on
your property is residential and
agriculture and a lot of zoning is that
it does it's residential but it allows
some agricultural uses that would be
okay but if it's strictly residential
then then it's it's not allowed so
that's an issue you know you want to
make sure you check with your town
zoning office no
no
oh the question is whether what if you
are in the adirondack park
to my knowledge there's no restriction
on growing
hemp is a statutorily recognized
agricultural crop now so if you could
it's just like growing corn or anything
else so
the zoning of the parcel
okay so when people apply to us for a
license they have to register the fields
on which they intend to grow hemp so
they provide the gps coordinates for
each field and it that they want to grow
on so it's
it's up to you as the property owner or
a lessee leaser of property that you can
you just tell us whatever field you want
to grow on provide us with the gps
coordinates and the acreage
of the field that's another thing i
mentioned gps coordinates are far and
away the thing that holds up more
applications than anything else that
people just are not getting the gps
right
an easy way to do it is go on google
maps put in your address
you click on the little satellite photo
that pops up in the bottom of the screen
you can zoom into your exact field and
right click on the center of the field
just right click on your cursor the gps
coordinates pop up
mary
no
so the question was does do you have to
re you have to notify me every year of
your of the field location
you
the license is good for three years so
actually you'll have to do a planting
report with us and you have to register
your field with the fsa so i guess yes
we would get that information
each year but
there's no requirement that you do any
amendment or any extra application with
us
so the question is is there any uh
what's the cost for sampling and testing
and is there a circumstance where you
wouldn't have to have testing done if
you're a researcher or breeder the cost
for the sampling is something that you
would arrive at with your sampling agent
there's no set costs we don't we don't
dictate what those people are charging
and the labs similarly are
you know whatever the labs are charging
if when you apply you apply for a
research license there will be some
performance based sampling
that you could do you could do less you
would you may be exempt entirely however
if you have signed up for a research
license you nothing you grow can move
into commerce
so you can't sell anything so it's uh
it's really research
did that answer your question
yeah
so yes that would definitely count
against you yeah if if you're not
registered as a researcher your your
your crop has to be sampled and tested
and that's that that's the
onus that the usda has put on us
if i can interrupt i think we have some
registered sampling agents in the room
uh so part of the
purpose of this event is networking so
if you're a registered sampling agent
raise your hand or stand up
okay i see a couple you see tony i know
is a registered sampling agent and a
cornell graduate
so uh
if you have not contracted with a
sampling agent yet and you're getting
ready to harvest very soon
there are at least a couple of them here
another
question chuck do you know i i don't
the question was on
a typical cost of coming out and doing
the sampling sampling agents have to buy
some supplies they have to have
insurance some of them will charge for
mileage not mileage we have sampling
agents that cover every county in the
state so
if they're charging mileage you want to
look for an agent in your county
again they work as independent
contractors we can't tell them what to
charge but we do give them parameters of
things that
you know they need to charge for their
time and whatnot so typically i would
say it's somewhere around
and again this this is just a ballpark
number but somewhere around 200 250 to
come out and have a sample taken sent to
the lab most of the lab tests if you're
just looking to do a
cannabinoid profile i think they run
around 65 75
but again that's that's dependent on the
lab that you choose we have labs in new
york state and labs in many other states
so it doesn't necessarily have to be
tested in new york state
and you'll see on the website there's
probably seven or eight different states
listed
with labs as well all the sampling
agents are primarily in new york state i
think there's one or two that live
in bordering states but most of them are
still in new york state
thanks how are we doing
yeah we're we're getting close to out of
time here have time for one more
question if there is one
okay yeah go ahead
so the question is will
you mean between cbd and and fiber and
grain hemp
yeah so
right well we would hope that for the
fiber and grain varieties typically
they're
they're not like cbd varieties and they
don't tend to go hot as often
so this will be part of the
performance-based sampling program that
we're establishing we have to have
enough data to be able to justify that
to the usda so we need we're still
collecting data on varieties
once we have that data
combined with you know a list of
certified seed and then also how
if the grower has been a good actor in
the past those things will all be taken
into consideration and so the fiber and
grain varieties will likely be
they would be the ones to more likely be
excused from sampling than the cbd
varieties for instance but that doesn't
mean that no cbd varieties will be you
know excused it's possible
i'm going to be around
so
you can ask me questions all day if you
like okay thanks very much tim
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu